there are huge numbers of people out  there that are still undecided and I  also suspect a lot of people when  opinion polls bring them up perhaps not  telling the truth whether you call it  personal or not elections are about  choosing the team to take the country  forward if we want to call some talents  and our austerity agenda then we need to  vote SMP I don't believe they will work  and I hope they don't work this is  general elections taking place here this  is their rough and tumble politics when  i boarded a thread depends on your of  banging at your own experiences it  definitely is yeah firstly people talk  wrong way around does it all tasted say  yes I'm sorry all right okay I believe  this is one of the most significant  events of the campaign so far in  Scotland  thank thank you to both ads